all right back to the paper uh we're
coming towards the end of question five
almost
we've got here um the first question
that is of um
the nature of a recursive sequence so it
says a sequence is defined by
a n equals and then you can see you get
a n by looking at the previous term
uh a n minus one you do make some
changes to it you double it
and then you do some other stuff to do
with whatever part of the sequence
you're up to okay
so there's the definition of the
sequence because it's a recursive
sequence you need to know a starting
point like a seed okay
start at 2 and then just keep on doing
the pattern on and on and what you're
asked to prove is that this
is the general formula for integers
n is greater than or equal to 1. so how
do we go about this
again even though it is not stated
explicitly i hope you remember
this is a perfect tool for mathematical
induction um how could you know that
without having just like memorized it
you're looking at an integer sequence
you're looking at going from one term
to the next and so we can we we also
have something that looks very
suspicious in like a base case that sort
of establishes this is how it works and
this is how it continues
so even though the words proved by
mathematical induction do not appear
anywhere in this question
there were enough clues within the
question to nudge you in that direction
so let's have a look at the solution now
the way i started was i said okay well
i'm going to test just like i bring in
any other
proof by induction i've got n equals 1
and what i do is i say well let's have a
look
at the uh what the recursive formula
tells us recalling that recursive the
recursive formula
is this value over here this expression
rather this function
i'm going to put in you know equals 1
which means i've got a sub 1 minus 1
which is
a 0 which i already have established so
i get that
that's what i do from the recursive
formula and then i check
the thing that i'm trying to prove i
check it for the base case now
you can see this is the result i'm
trying to prove so what i do is i say
and i label it by the way from this from
this particular formula
let's see what happens if i put in 1 now
n equals 1 what do i get
i get 2 plus 3 plus 1 which is 6. the
same thing that the recursive
formula told me so that's a really
promising sign
i've got my base case it works the
assumption
hardly takes any time at all but then i
get into the proof step now
it doesn't take that many lines of
working certainly far less than the
previous
proof by induction that we saw and
that's because as i pointed out the
beginning of this question
recursive formulas are kind of built for
proof by induction because induction is
itself a recursive
process it establishes something and
then looks back at that and then uses
that
to establish a new thing and looks back
at that so because
mathematical induction is recursive by
nature recursive formulas are just mints
made for this particular method
so here is me oopsy daisy here is me
writing out the k plus 1 case and then
what i do is i
use the recursive formula to see what
happens if i say
a sub k plus 1 and then i sort of
evaluate there using
the formula as presented and at this
point i say hold on
my assumption has to do with this a k
term right there okay see there it is a
k and what i'm doing is i'm substituting
it for
this 2 to the k plus 3 k plus 1. so
that's why you can see it appears here
and i've sort of separated in the
brackets and i've said by assumption
which you always do
in a proof by mathematical induction to
clarify your communication
once i've done that it's just a matter
of expanding and collecting like terms
so
you can see it unfolds here um all of
the two to the k
terms is that's that's all of them right
i've got these um
these k terms there's 6k that comes from
here minus 3k it simplifies out
and then plus 2 plus 2 equals 4.
and that's it so really all of the
challenges were on the interpretation
the the actual proof by mathematical
induction itself
is very very straightforward but knowing
how to read a recursive formula keep
doing that by accident
read a recursive formula and then to use
that to incorporate that
into your proof by mathematical
induction that was the only part of that
that was tricky all right final question
in number five within the set of
integers prove
by the contrapositive that if n squared
minus 6 n plus 5 is even then
n is odd so this is a classic number
theory or discrete mathematics question
to do
something to do with number parity
evenness and oddness
so you even get given the specific
method that's prescribed proved by the
contra
positive so how does this work well the
first thing you need to know is
what is the contrapositive of this
particular statement once you've got
that
what you want to do is use that prove it
and then once you've proven the
contrapositive that is logically
equivalent
to proving the original statement so
let's see at
what that looks like here comes question
5e
so here's the original statement right
so the contrapositive
of p implies
q the contrapositive of that is to
uh to get the negation of everything and
then
reverse the order so it would be not q
implies not p now you can see how i've
done this right
um if i'm calling this part p
then not p would be n squared minus 6 n
plus 5 is
odd which sure enough is what you can
see down here on the end
so there's my not p and then what is not
q
well if q is n is odd then not q is n is
even
so you can see what i've done there is
i've taken this one
i've negated it and put it first and in
exactly the same way
there's this one i've negated it and
then i put it last
so happy times this is the
contrapositive
and uh now i can work with it so if n is
even
what does that mean well i state n
equals 2p that's a nice
generic way to talk about any even kind
of numbers don't forget to specify that
p
itself has to be an integer otherwise
you could have two times a half and
that's not
an even number and then i say well if if
n equals 2p
what does that tell me about n squared
minus 6n plus 5. so
i do my substitution in here and what
i'm trying to
show is that n squared plus minus 6 n
plus 5 is odd
well an odd number is of the form you
know an even number plus 1 or an even
number minus 1. so if i can get it into
that arrangement
i'm good to go so i do my substitution i
expand out
and i notice oh i've got all these even
terms here if i factorize out the two it
becomes very
obvious so i've done that and then it's
plus one right
but then what i notice is this guy here
it must be also
itself an even number sorry rather not
an even number but a whole number right
if p is a whole number then squaring it
doubling it subtracting etc
you still end up with an integer so
therefore you can see in this line i
have
firmly established n squared minus 6n
plus 5
it's double an integer plus 1.
this is the particular integer that's
being doubled so therefore it must be
odd
if i started with the assumption that n
was even so i've proved the
contrapositive
that means that the original result
which is logically equivalent
is done so that was the trickiest part
of this question
i think the algebra wasn't complicated
but you needed to know
what the contrapositive was and what its
logical relation to the original
statement
also was